hi there Steve Kaufman haven't done a
video in a while i've i've had that
family visiting my son and his family
from the UK my brother from toronto
kicked out of my office so i'm doing it
from a different location and I thought
I would do a video here because I had a
question from I think he calls himself
the seductive arts one of my viewers who
said you know how do you deal with the
problem of learning some of the basic
vocabulary because I think he's learning
Italian and French and he listens to a
lot of news and so he has a lot of the
vocabulary that relates to news and
politics and doesn't know the name of
everyday items in those languages and
what should I do and and this is a
subject that comes up all the time
someone mentioned before that they had
been studying through a lot of listening
and reading and then they went somewhere
and it took a course and the teacher
said you know your case is quite typical
you don't know the names of the most
common things in the language and the
other day I was talking to my check
tutor Andre and he started talking about
food and said now we're going to talk
about the names of the different food
stuffs are you know items on a menu or
food products in check and I said stop
you know I won't be able to learn them
because I don't have a daily need for
those words and so on the subject of how
do we learn the basic vocabulary I
believe that we learn the vocabulary
that's important to us and it's not
necessarily the names of different food
items that you're going to buy in a
store or in a restaurant it's not
necessarily the name for comb or
refrigerator or even basic things in
daily life if you're not at in fact
living in the language you don't need
those basic words if i lived in the
czech republic and if i was eating every
day and going to the store every day
then i would quickly learn those words
but it's pointless for me I believed to
have a lesson on the
a different you know names of food
dishes in check if I won't encounter
those words again for you know months so
to me because I'm interested in
following the new following the news
then economics terms political terms a
lot of terms about you know in that
regard or from that point of view or in
my view and these kinds of words that
come up in a discussion are easier for
me to learn because they come up more
often and I don't think there's any
particular benefit in trying to teach
the so-called basic words the most
common words will come up in any case no
matter what we're using as learning
content and it's also true that in the
beginning we tend to learn terms like
hello how are you my name is when why
we're who and these will come up anyway
and it is helpful in the beginning to
use simpler shorter dialogues but I
personally find that I find move along
quickly to more demanding content it's
still going to be seventy eighty percent
very common vocabulary so I'm continuing
to reinforce my grasp of a lot of a
common vocabulary and I'm developing
specialized vocabulary in areas of
interest and as that area of interest
changes or as my needs change then i'll
have an opportunity to learn other
vocabulary and it has never bothered me
that in a language where i might be able
to discuss economics i might be quite
clueless in everyday things when i lived
in japan I could do business in Japanese
my wife who certainly couldn't do
business in Japanese was much better at
the store buying things you know
vegetables and fruit than she knew the
names of all these things and
communicated very comfortably with a
grocer so you learn the language that
you need for your particular situation
so I'm not a big believer in this idea
of the basic vocabulary it'll come
anyway and north any more than I'm a
believer in
learning the basic grammar first I mean
as I've said before you can have a sense
of what the what some of the grammatical
issues are but the idea that you could
nail down tenses or nailed down cases
early on and your language learning is
is not certainly not the way I learned
so I just thought I'd do that because I
had a request from the seductive arts or
whatever his name was on the subject of
what to do when you seem to have these
gaps in your vocabulary which often are
some very basic words that's perfectly
normal in my opinion and if you you know
if you have a method of learning which
which basically enables you to learn
from things of interest to you or you're
always doing meaningful things in the
language you don't have an artificial
dialogue about someone's refrigerator
you are basically doing things that
interest you or you're engaged in
discussions around things that are
meaningful to you you will learn the
vocabulary that is useful for that
context and as these contexts change and
as other words come up more often in
your reading listening speaking then
you'll learn those words if you have a
solid base in the language that's never
too late and it won't be difficult to
learn the names for pen pencil
refrigerator exercise book or whatever
other so-called basic words you may need
so there you have it thank you for
listening